welcome to this video yeah as you see
this is something different and it's an
update on the opening challenge subject
and what I can tell you is I had
completed one week of opening challenge
now and already uploaded it to YouTube
what you see is an excerpt air of them
oh my you tube um what it's called the
dashboard or something like that it's a
dashboard yeah okay I've done this 21
videos with the opening challenge and it
was good fun it was good fun what I did
is I met all the criteria that were
given the thing that I did not manage
was the pond siani challenge it was to
play the pantheon he given given any
opportunity oops sorry about that given
any opportunity and win two games and it
was impossible because i only had one
pond siani game as you see here it says
one con siani I only applied a form in
all of the games with white but I only
got 15 which is a statistically speaking
quite rare but it happened um in general
and what I did in this in this in this
week here um and you see it by the way
here yeah 23rd of june twenty second of
june so this will be uploaded in about a
month or released in about a month
because i have pre pude used so many
videos that this is simply yeah next
next in line and what I basically did
with white I played one year for and I
played the lines that are usually
suggest to my students to be honest not
gambit lines or something but pretty
pretty normal lines that I feel are
appropriate for players that don't want
to study for hours and hours because in
my lessons openings are not a focus so
what I did is luckier play the sea sea
sea fresa sian i played the raw salim
abbud Bishop b5 here there should be
five check the moscow there was so that
was funny i was black with Rosalie my
I'm sorry but I played it also with
white the cop heck variation this is the
right penalty
something with c3 as well at the French
tarish with white one point siani which
I don't recommend really but was part of
the challenge another French tarish I
got what else did I get I got a modern
defense with my idea and with black
another I'll up in here yeah and with
black I had I tried for bengkos and
stuff here I had a bank or gambit this
was a tried banker but he declined it I
had Sicilians a couple Russell Lima with
black yeah Bishop b5 against mr. Dover
on the yard bird um what else I played
the the Dutch stone war with black so
with black I tried for mixed back that
meeting the criteria none of my usual
openings and with wider played 1.e4 but
more of a yeah more of a solid normal
style let's say what I also would
recommend to two people to to study that
they don't want to invest so much time
on openings so it was a good fun we I
don't spoil the results I can tell that
i wasn't dissatisfied it was okay i only
had to play two or three games that were
a bit tricky in the opening but you will
see i think it will be a will be okay um
yeah and what to do next I really like
this idea of spicing up the the daily
Blitz videos with something like that
the issue is that i'm lacking time at
the moment to do more sophisticated
videos if i do one of those like middle
game themed and game team videos it
doesn't look like much but have an hour
video at the end it's like a two or two
and a half hour thing of work you have
to record it you have to prepare it and
actually invest time to analyze things
before I'm not just sitting there and
talking something that comes to my mind
I really have script young and this this
takes lots of time which I don't have at
the moment what I do is I'd like to play
this blitz also from a personal
enjoyment and this is something that
that can be done with
current time frame so I want to make it
less repetitive so those ideas like the
opening challenge are great there are
also some similarly themed suggestions
in them in the threats here on the
YouTube video also on reddit I'm doing
things with the openings yeah like using
dice to determine what I'm play on
player themed week like one week off
let's say Kings fee and shadow or one
week of Sicilian with black if possible
and ce4 with white if possible or okay
with right you cannot really yeah they
cannot hinder you from playing c4 so
like predetermine what what to play an
idea that I liked us to to make it 2-2
to make a subject for a week and then do
some one video at the end of the week or
maybe before that I know where I'm kind
of reviewing what happened yeah they're
21 games I mean it's not a huge
statistical base but it's something that
you can use and may be trying to give an
overview of the current state where
what's happening in a particular opening
or what a particular opening or
structure is all about this is also
something that I can yeah they can
imagine to do in the future yeah okay i
hope you like this this feedback there
i'm very glad that I got so many
responses on that subject because I was
really thinking about doing something
with the daily Blitz videos but didn't
know what exactly and this opening
challenge was really a great idea by
this user that they posted that so i
think i will do similarly themed thing
some in the future in fact i will record
more videos because and why I'm
pre-recording that much is because of
the longer vacation mid-june starting
mid june and i have to pre pre do stuff
so i'm going to continue recording blitz
in the next couple of days to be sure
that this gap when i'm away is filled
and they have to see what exactly i'm
going to do i'm reading those some those
responses careful
and going to consider what to do how
also like the idea of playing I'm
playing motion pink sharper opening sir
and I didn't really I mean I didn't play
play necessary boring stuff Ian in those
sessions but I didn't have any any
gambits and I played the banker once but
and try to get there but I really didn't
have much my chances there to play shop
but I can also imagine to to do a gambit
gambit week here let's say but what I
don't do it I simply won't i won't play
nonsense openings like I don't know the
globe or I don't know the Latvian or
something and something that's really
rubbish because it's totally against my
my approach to the game I'd like to play
em yeah play things that are really
sound or at least them not easily
refutable yeah if you play the angular
gambit or something you just lose if
they have vague idea how to play so yeah
this is this is simply how i play i
cannot i cannot change my personality as
a player just to make the videos a
little bit different so um this is not
going to happen but i don't mind to play
stuff like the banco gambit or the Evans
gambit or what else is there yeah maybe
even the Smith Mora which is a little
bit a little bit on the risky side but
it's blitz chess and blitz is the the
moral gambit is certainly okay which is
not true for for something like the
Latvian which is just rubbished in any
time control um okay so this is an
update on what happened i'm going to do
something similar in the next videos
that are well released after this yeah
like we're talking about end of June so
please don't be surprised that you don't
see those videos so soon it's only will
all be like in 3-4 weeks that there will
be released ok guys thanks for watching
and thanks a lot for participating so
much in the discussion on this ok guys
bye